c'est le nom de notre chronique en
compagnie de Nord porter de retour de
mission bonjour Mélina Huet bonjour
Damien merci de venir sur ce plateau ce
matin avec Catherine Noris Trent et ride
Abu zaïed il y a quelques jours vous
étiez encore en Ukraine vous avez passé
trois semaines dans l'est du pays dans
le Dombasle la région de kerki mais
aussi dans le sud
on a vu vos reportages durant ces trois
semaines quels sont les rencontres qui
vous ont marqué d'abord sur le terrain
c'est difficile de de faire un résumé
exhaustif de toutes les personnes qu'on
a rencontré moi je pense immédiatement à
la force de ces mères courage qu'on a
rencontré interviewé notamment à isum
c'est dans la région de harkis dans le
nord-est c'est une ville qui a subi plus
de 5 mois d'occupation et vous voyez ces
images derrière extrait d'un reportage
qu'on a réalisé avec avec mes collègues
il y a cette femme qui qui s'appelle
Margarita et qui donc a élevé ces trois
enfants pendant la guerre qui a été
confronté à de nombreuses reprises aux
soldats russes et qui n'avaient
absolument pas besoin qu'on lui souhaite
bon courage parce qu'elle avait une
force complètement transcendante elle
répliquait aux soldat russe qui lui
refusaient l'accès à la nourriture au
bois de chauffage avec une force qu'on
imagine à peine il y a aussi Antonina
qui est une voisine à elle qui a donné
naissance au milieu des bombardements
qui a dû trouver une assistance médicale
en plein milieu de l'occupation dont la
toute petite fille Caterina a à peine
trois mois donc vraiment la force de ces
mères courage et puis ce qui nous a
marqué évidemment c'est c'est la la
difficulté à aller de l'avant quand on a
tout perdu je pense à Alexander qui est
le patron d'un hôtel 4 étoiles qu'on a
rencontré cette fois asiatoïs qui est
une ville du Dombas où les allégeances
entre Moscou et kiffe sont partagés et
qui a subi plusieurs mois d'occupation
pendant quasiment 100 jours et avec nous
il est revenu dans son hôtel qui a été
complètement détruit et là il s'est
effondré parce qu'il découvrait cet
hôtel complètement à terre avec des
vitres explosées et ils nous disait on a
besoin on a besoin de vous on a besoin
que vous nous aidiez à reconstruire et
puis nous psychologiquement on a besoin
de retrouver ce
cette vie touristique qu'on connaissait
ça s'appelait la Suisse du Dombas avant
et puis la dernière personne à qui je
pense et Luda Luda c'est une femme qui
faisait des retraites de yoga dans sa
toute petite maison et qui nous a
accueilli au milieu de ces champs de
lavande avec un grand sourire ce qui
nous a beaucoup étonné jusqu'à ce
qu'elle craque complètement je vous
propose de l'écouter
quand elle parle des orques elle elle
parle des soldats russes c'est un
qualificatif évidemment très péjoratif
que certains Ukrainiens utilisent pour
qualifier les soldats russes emprunter à
l'imaginaire on pense évidemment au
Seigneur des Anneaux mais pas que donc
il y a cette colère aussi des habitants
donc des reportages c'est des rencontres
comment est-ce que cette population a
vécu l'entrée dans suites guerre je
rappelle que c'est pas la première fois
que vous réalisez des reportages dans
cette guerre en Ukraine vous y êtes allé
à plusieurs reprises est-ce que vous
avez senti en changement de mentalité
chez ses Ukrainiens que vous avez
rencontré entre votre première et votre
dernière mission
ce qui nous marque c'est vraiment toutes
les étapes par lesquelles sont passées
les habitants
la sidération la résignation la
résilience on parle énormément de
résilience et c'est le cas il y a une
force encore une fois et un courage
assez important des populations civiles
qui vivent cette guerre et puis il y a
cette colère quand on est arrivé nous en
octobre il s'est passé beaucoup de
choses et il y a eu notamment cette
campagne de bombardements massive qui a
transformé cette ce choc premier en
colère qui est un moteur en réalité pour
dire mais en fait vous pensiez nous
abattre en faisant cela en nous frappant
sur la totalité du territoire après huit
mois de guerre et ben au contraire nous
ça nous ça nous requin que ça nous
motive et ce qui nous a frappé surtout
avec les équipes sur le terrain c'est
l'humour l'humour des Ukrainiens et
notamment comment ils emploient les
mêmes sur Internet les gifs on peut en
voir quelques-uns dès le début de la
guerre il y avait ce premier gif qui dit
avec Homer Simpson à cet enfant le
premier c'est normal depuis 2019 et on
voit Bart Simpson en Vladimir Poutine
derrière prêt à exploser une chaise sur
sur la tête d'Homer Simpson en disant
voilà on avait enfin un été sympa à
venir et bim il y a la guerre mais pas
seulement pendant des mois et des mois
ça a été des même des gifs là vous voyez
ce gif il y a carrément un compte qui
parodie le crinian mme fors pour
parodier les forces armées ukrainiennes
avec cette personne représentant la
Russie qui veut frapper un panneau et
qui se le prend en pleine tête il y a
vraiment cette volonté de faire feu de
tout bois de rire de tout ce qui leur
arrive et nous quand on y était il y a
eu l'explosion du pont de Crimée je sais
pas si vous en souvenez entre la
péninsule Crimée annexée par par les par
les Russes et la Russie continentale et
ben vous voyez là ce petit meuble j'ai
juste laissé écouter un petit peu le son
c'est Marilyn Monroe qui chante happy
birthday to you Mister parce qu'il se
trouve que la veille de l'explosion se
pont c'était l'anniversaire de Vladimir
Poutine voilà la pose ukrainienne aussi
qui qui s'est dit et ben on va faire un
timbre à l'effigie de l'explosion de ce
pont avec on voit cette scène très
connue de Titanic avec Rose et Jack et
le pont qui explose derrière on a
coutume de dire que que l'humour c'est
la politesse du désespoir je sais pas si
le terme désespoir est approprié mais en
tout cas oui c'est une c'est un
mécanisme de survie qui s'est enclenché
chez les Ukrainiens avec l'humour une
dernière question comment est-ce qu'on
fait pour couvrir une guerre dans un
pays aussi vaste que l'Ukraine et avec
plein de lignes de front différentes
c'est vrai que c'est un pays qui est
très grand l'Ukraine c'est plus de 600
000 km², on peut peut-être apercevoir
une carte du pays très très grand plus
grand que la France et on s'est rendu
dans plein d'endroits il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à couvrir il se
trouve que pendant les trois semaines où
nous étions dans l'est de l'Ukraine mais
également dans le sud dans la région des
apollodia de Helson il s'est passé
énormément de choses il y a eu la
finalisation de l'annexion des
territoires
occupés par Moscou il y a eu
l'appropriation de la centrale de zapolé
déjà par la Russie avec la visite de
Raphaël grossi de la IEA on a eu le
plein Caire donc qui a explosé on a eu
ses frappes massifs dans le pays à
partir du 10 octobre on a l'impression
de courir un petit peu derrière
l'actualité quand on est dans ce pays
pour vous donner un exemple très concret
pour aller de la région de harkif
jusqu'à Zapo Legia on met minimum 7 à 8
heures de route donc on doit faire
preuve de bon sens de choisir ses
renoncer on a coutume de dire et c'est
vrai que on a la chance d'avoir de
nombreuses équipes sur le terrain là
vous voyez les frappes que le pays a
subi à partir du 10 octobre à ce moment
là on se dit ok qu'est-ce qu'on fait où
est-ce qu'on va on a la chance d'avoir
des équipes sur le terrain envoyer
depuis Paris puis on a la chance d'avoir
un correspondant que l'hiver crack qui
assure également l'antenne de France 24
et qui nous permet aussi de faire notre
travail correctement sur sur le terrain
sur la chaîne francophone et sur la
chaîne anglophone aussi merci beaucoup
Mélina on peut trouver tout reportage
sur France 24 com et on se retrouvera
pour pour d'autres reportages